on Wednesday NASA is firing up their new
solid rocket boosters for two minute
qualification test so why should you
care well because of this little red
planet if you care about people going to
Mars these Rockets are the only way to
get there but what is a solid rocket
booster it's one of two rockets that
will be attached to the main engines of
a new space vehicle called the Space
Launch System or SLS these boosters the
most powerful ever built use powdered
aluminum as fuel and generate 3.6
million pounds of thrust that's the same
as 14 Boeing 747s at full takeoff power
so why does NASA need new boosters well
because they need to send more stuff
further into space and to do that you
need more power once completed the SLS
will be taller than the Statue of
Liberty and be able to send a record 70
tons of fuel parts and people into deep
space destinations what are they
planning to launch with all that brust
SLS is first mission will be unmanned
traveling past the moon once deemed safe
for human exploration the SLS will
propel the Orion crew capsule to distant
asteroids and hopefully sometime around
November 2018 it will head to Mars so
what are they testing a lot 102
different factors including abstruse
engineering principles like thrust time
curve and nozzle throat erosion but
essentially it's a temperature
performance test they'll heat 154
footlong 801 ton booster to 90 degrees
simulating a hot day
the cold weather test will take place in
early 2016 and then the rocket should be
ready to fly during the test the engine
will burn for two minutes and 6 seconds
the length of an actual launch it's also
the length of this video so by now the
tests would be over